in the past four decades my guest
tonight has starred in films like st.
Elmo's fire and Wayne's World as well as
television series like The West Wing and
Parks and Rec he now hosts the podcasts
literally with Rob Lowe and it's a huge
success please welcome Rob Lowe Rob
Congrats on the podcast it's doing great
thank you it's really exciting and for
those of you don't know I do it with in
conjunction with Conan's company and I'm
just once again sucking off your
intellectual property Conan I listen you
know I'm just drafting behind you as
I've done my entire career your entire
career going back to the mid 80s was
drafting off of my success even though I
was a complete unknown and a failure at
the time I don't know how you did that
but I somehow knew that our paths would
cross in the podcast world that we would
we would be the dirt where the darlings
in the podcast world this week I mean
this way well you know we'll be that for
this week and then we have to find a new
medium next week next week that's right
yes I'm going to go into the
interpretive dance touring business next
week
you'd be good and I think you'd be I
think I've seen you do interpreting
interpretive dance
that's called me walking that's just
what I look like when I walk I you know
there's a couple things to talk about
first of all we're we're going through
this long long quarantine and I am
falling apart day by day my hair is the
longest it's ever been that the
pompadour has collapsed collapsed I look
like I'm having a nervous breakdown you
look better than ever and it didn't
rages me what are you doing well I don't
know if you noticed but I have sort of
Backstreet Boys highlights in my hair
right now I didn't know it yeah that's
it I was so bored that I was gonna go
for the Robert DeNiro Mohawk and taxi
driver and I got talked out of it good
and I was like well then I want to just
put really crazy highlights like like
I'm a member of NSYNC and so it's not
like I I'm totally keeping up with my
you know heritage here
I'm slipping look look what's become of
me well first of all it looks it looks
fantastic
thank you you look good as always I know
that your wife is a makeup specialist
artist yes she is so she probably gives
you a little help and I'm assuming that
you um consume some sort of devil blood
at night there's something you do that
you're not telling anybody you have a
frozen you one of those chambers that
freezes your body and face do you have
one of those Oh like a cyber genetic
like the kind of thing that Walt Disney
is supposedly buried in don't act like
you don't have one it's you know you're
I don't know what you're talking about
yeah yeah yeah I don't know what you're
talking about Cohn and I know I would
never have anything like that ever
okay all right okay take it easy it's
too close by the way I would do that in
two seconds if there was such a thing I
would sleep in it and I would I would be
so down to clown with that I would what
are you drinking there is that some sort
of special juice I need to know about
this is this is that what did you say it
was the blood of Devils a special juice
what is that yeah is that like is that
some I know your aunt you have you once
told me that you keep little
moisturizers that you yourself make in
your pocket and you sometimes moisturize
I do iin ulcers I am my own skincare
line profile cobalt and I do have one
our biggest seller is an under-eye
rollerball that helps you with aging and
fine lines and wrinkles and like if I
come into a meeting and I want a little
like pull it out did bit a bit did it
and no one's the wiser I pitched my own
line of face care products for men a few
years ago and the tagline was so you can
look like Conan I lost everything I lost
I lost everything I lost the house lost
the beach house everything gone
apparently no one wants to look like
Conan
well you I can tease now for the
audience that you are on the podcast
coming up and I think your week after
next and you talked about how when you
walk on the beach
that you look like Rose Kennedy at the
end yeah it's true yeah when she and I
thought when she was a hundred and seven
and they would take her to the beach and
they would just drape her in blankets
and hats she looked like a pile of
laundry that was tumbling day and that's
yeah I think that's what I think of you
you know and I think of you just in the
neighborhood at your little beach house
you your clam shack do you like to
escape to I'll know it's you if it looks
literally if it looks like laundry and
blankets who I am gonna be oh there's
Conan I'll go say aye
ma'am now I do need your advice on
something which is we moved into a
theater a very nice
a prominent comedy theater here in Los
Angeles called Largo
yeah and we're doing shows out of there
now I know that you've had legitimate
theater experience maybe you could give
me some tips you performed in the West
End in London I think didn't you I did
it's a the the I performed at the Royal
Haymarket in the West End which is sort
of the biggest most traditional oldest
Theatre in the West End you know there
they have because it's in the UK they
have a Royal Box for the Queen if she
Danes to come to see the entertainment I
don't know what the like would be at
Largo if they have the UK royal bar I
don't know where would be who would the
Box before at Largo in Los Angeles it
would probably be where the director of
the department of water you know yes
that would that would be there that's
the equivalent of royalty in LA as who
get who can get you extra water for your
lawn would be something I thought it
might be like a Kardashian box well if
you're talking about true royalty now
yes well yeah exactly so the Royal Box
is you know obviously the Queen is not
really into theatre so it's empty all
the time but I was doing a few good men
mm-hmm with Aaron Sorkin and one day the
box was had people in it and I and I
noticed God was doing that you can't
handle the truth seeing the big
fireworks scene at the end and I looked
over and they were having sex there's a
communal royal in the Royal Box having
sex
90% having sex with total abandoned by
the way and what when I I was I couldn't
believe it and apparently that it was a
thing like if you do enough Theatre in
the Royal in the in the West End this
couple is notorious like it's their
thing oh that's what they do that's what
they do
yeah it is it is their thing how they
get into the Royal Box I don't know but
um so I'm just saying Cafe Largo you
know it's the live theater Conan you you
need to be ready for anything that could
happen and literally anything and
basically here with about for socially
distance male crew members wearing masks
are any of them having sex three of them
yeah well there you go hey I want to ask
you about something during uh you you
have so many great stories and you've
been in the business for such a long
time you have this I heard a rumor I
don't know if it's true but of course
everyone's obsessed with Michael Jordan
and that documentary the last dance
which people know yeah fantastic and
whole new appreciation as if we needed
to be reminded but we did about just how
intense Michael Jordan but in his career
I'm told that you at a celebrity event
to raise money a charity event who were
the celebrity coach and you were the
first coach then that coached Michael
Jordan and Magic Johnson when they were
on the same team they hadn't never
played together this was before the
Olympics right you know it's funny you
get to a certain age and you have your
memories and you remember something and
you go that can't be true that really
didn't I'm imagining that so Magic
Johnson is this week's current guest on
the podcast and I asked him I said
remember when I coached your celebrity
charity game in Los Angeles in the 80s
and you and and Michael played together
that wasn't the first time you guys ever
set foot of the court together was it he
said yes it absolute
was so that is a 100% true story you
were that you were the celebrity coach
in that situation I don't know what I
would do I would either do it absolutely
nothing or I would get in their faces a
lot yes the annoying would it be better
yeah yeah play basketball better I did I
did get to the point where like I mean
I'm one of the celebrities and I've been
doing nothing I mean what are you gonna
do I've been sitting on the bench for
the whole game and I figured I better do
there's like two minutes left in the
game and I figured I better do something
is I called a 20-second timeout by the
way I was dressed like Pat Riley as one
does the Armani suit on I ever her
slicked back yeah and I called a
20-second timeout when I got out there
they huddled around and they all looked
at me and I I think we had like chrome
alone was on the team Mark Jackson was
on the team I mean everybody my and I
had nothing to say of course and I
looked over though at Michael and he was
pissed and he looked at magic in a
magics being his magic self having a
good time I think the score was 240 at
that point no one played any defense
Michael was like hey men you wouldn't
win this and all of a sudden you can see
the light bulb go off and magics Henry
like oh Jesus Christ he means it yeah
then of course it got really competitive
but that's who Michael was it was is all
fun and games and for money but Michael
wanted to win 100% all the time I love
it I love it it's a you're supposed to
be just joking around it's for charity
and even in that moment which when you
see the documentary you could totally
see that I think I would have pulled him
from the game I think I should have I
should have that's what you should have
done you should have said Michael I'm
making you out you don't have what it
takes and can you imagine can you
imagine what he would have done I call
time out for the last shot and I make
Michael pass the ball
Michael so in this you just got it
you just got a hit you know Mike Shrek
whoever like me got like some celeb some
celebrity who clearly can't play you
know so yes you have to
hit Balki from perfect strangers for the
final shot 100% I should have done it
that would have been great I was too
scared I was intimidated around those
guys they were they there was a moment
where Karl Malone ran past magic and
Michael and I we were all sitting that
Julie what a bad coach I was because
there was an actual moment where both
magic and Michael Jordan were on the
bench with you which would mean a
terrible coach I was but I remember it
vividly because Karl Malone ran past us
and it was like a freight train where
that the dust and the air travels behind
it and debris I just remember them both
looking each other because I think
Malone was a rookie yeah say would you
ever take it take a hard foul from that
man and they were like hell no no no you
know another documentary that's been
huge of course during this quarantine is
Tiger King you posted this great shot of
yourself as Joe exotic this is what
happens this is what happens when a you
have too much time in your hands and
your wife was one of the leading makeup
artists in the business we do we just
went to the Attic got the old makeup kit
out and I spent an entire day just
having the most fun being jogs otic and
I put it up for fun and then the next
thing you know Riya and Murphy was like
let's let's go out and make this as a
real movie so we went out and tried to
get the rights which of course we're
already gone but who has you know has
the rights turns out a consortium
because I think is it always consortiums
that have rights as opposed to one
person
I think consortiums I always think of as
evil - which is probably true cages
involved in it so Nic Cage oh my god
okay yeah Nic Cage is always part of
every consortium is me though if there's
a consortium trying to buy up all the
oil in Alaska Nick Cage is in there
yes that's read saying iridium yes so
it's a Nic Cage consortium oh my god yes
I I I stand down at the altar of the
notion of Nicolas Cage as The Lion King
I mean I got nothing to offer great he'd
be great but I get to say the picture
had me wanting to see you know I
thought this could happen when I saw the
roll it is the role of a lifetime like
when I watched that I was like you know
cuz whenever I usually I don't get to do
hardcore character stuff I mean I when I
did behind the candelabra yeah you know
I got to do a lot and I love it whenever
I can do prosthetic stuff it's just a
great escape for me and it's kind of
freeing and I thought this would be
great so I'm always looking for
something like it I forgot about behind
the candelabra that was fantastic and
you had your character who's a plastic
surgeon had an insane amount of the
prosthetics they did on you yeah
you were completely absurd looking and
then like most people who've had
terrible plastic surgery you were
completely unaware that you looked crazy
that was murder the character yeah and
not only that I'm a bad surgeon so when
I when I give Michael Douglas's liberace
surgery he said in its it's got his eyes
pulled like this and he says doctor will
my eyes ever be able to close and I say
probably not look at it this way you'll
always get to see people's reactions
when they see how great you look and I
don't know if you noticed but I look
very androgynous and there was a lot of
people playing sort of Fay and Raj and
his stuff and I wanted to stand out so I
was like I'll look in drogyn as' but I'm
gonna use the voice of the guy from the
Men's Wearhouse yes yeah you're gonna
like the way you look let me ask you
quickly about someone I think we both
met Chris Farley around the same time I
remember very clearly when he came to
Sarah out live and he was waiting for an
interview with Lauren and I think he had
to wait for two days outside Lauren's
office and so I ended up just clowning
around with this great new guy I'd never
met before named Chris Farley you met
him probably shortly after he was hired
for Sarah alive because you knew Lauren
you knew Lorne Michaels so how is that
when you met Chris cuz I know you
eventually worked with him in Tommy Boy
but you met him I think at Lauren's
house is that committed I met him at
Lauren's wedding and you know how you
there's certain people in life
that for whatever reason you remember
exactly where you were when you met them
mm-hmm and think about many people that
we meet famous not famous and we don't
remember where we met them for the first
time or what they were doing or how they
were standing Farley was one of those
guys probably because he was packed into
a suit that was 17 times too small for
him right and sweating like he had
jumped into Lake Michigan but he was
standing by the porta-potties and and
then of course his first acting job in a
movie was in Wayne's World 2 and then of
course we did Tommy Boy together and I
loved him he was funny and he and Spade
they would fight over me like I was the
hot girl they were they would get very
jealous of who was spending time with me
and it really made me laugh I understand
that I understand that always I'm always
jealous when I hear that you're spending
time with others one quick Farley story
is he loved to eat steak mm-hmm and I
took him to a steak house when we
wrapped Tommy Boy and he had two two
full bone-in Porter houses upon each
bite of the two full bone inch
porterhouses
he put an entire cube of butter on every
bite and when I was horrified like
Farley you doing he said it needs a hat
oh god bless him yes what a brilliantly
funny guy I've never I've never eaten
steak every time every bite of steak I
eat to this day I go wonderful I should
put a hat on this maybe not
Surgeon General might disagree I want to
make sure I one thing which is I'm gonna
I want to make sure that I promote your
you're terrific podcast but I also want
to mention something it's completely
unrelated to the business there is a
handmade t-shirt
that's available on Etsy that's getting
some notice and I just wanted to put a
word out for this t-shirt I guess do you
know who made this t-shirt if some woman
came up with it I believe is that
correct is it's it's it's a thing it's a
it started on the internet as a gift yep
and and now it is a shirt and I've never
seen one in person Yeah right you should
get one we should we feel we should each
get one and then we should you and I
should go out for steaks yes this shirt
says how many lows could Rob Lowe Rob if
Rob Lowe could rob lowes and and there's
information you can get this on Etsy and
apparently yeah it's the thing people
are getting these shirts I hope you're
getting a peek for this well here's my
cue well I was like hmm how do I get a
piece of this so I had my my managers
and agents call Lowe's and say this is
an internet thing it's a sensation it's
on the internet it's this kind of cool
subversive thing their shirts being sold
we should do something with Lowe's and
they were like we don't really see the
connection yeah your Lowe's forget it
yeah I think the wrong person
groundswell of connecting who needs it
yeah no they said no one's really buying
things over the internet so just related
that's what the people at Lowe's said
they didn't get it well I want to thank
you very much for your time a delight is
always talking to you and
congratulations again literally with Rob
Lowe which is currently number three on
the charts is available wherever you
consume because we all consume podcast
we don't just listen to them we consume
them well we not only do consume them we
put a hat on them and then we yeah
new episodes drop every Thursday and
it's really a delight it sounds like
you're having a lot of fun doing it yeah
I gotta tell you it has been I thought
it might be fun its way surpassed what I
thought it would be
the guests have been insane and just to
talk to ask the things of people that
that you just people don't get a chance
to ask them there's been
it's been great and I've been and I love
the response so far really great well
congratulations on that and I hope to
run into you soon I'm gonna have some
work done before I see you because I'm
ashamed I think I think you should Rob
Lowe thank you very much and take care
and I'll see you soon
all right thanks call me